le processus sera long l'édifice
patrimonial du 224 Place d'Youville sera
démentelée brique par briques après
cette étape les enquêteurs pourront
entrer dans les défis s'il commençait
les recherches des victimes les défis
s'abriter plusieurs logements Airbnb
dans un secteur où il est interdit de le
faire
cette chercheuse explique pourquoi il
est toujours possible de louer des
logements de courte durée en dehors des
zones permises si vous avez une annonce
Airbnb vous avez pas d'adresse donc si
vous voulez l'adresse il faut louer les
Airbnb et vous avez aussi pas
d'informations sur l'autre donc c'est un
profil en général qui est anonyme très
grande ligne une photo mais quand vient
le temps justement de faire la
régulation c'est très difficile à faire
et lorsqu'un citoyen souhaite formuler
une plainte la Ville de Montréal réfère
à un formulaire de Revenu Québec il faut
donner le nom et l'adresse du
propriétaire fautif des informations
parfois difficiles à obtenir les pois
sont dévolués à revenus Québec
d'inspection c'est-à-dire que les gens
sont conformes à la Loi sur
l'hébergement touristique dans ce cas-là
il y a des inspecteurs selon l'organisme
inside Airbnb à Montréal
92,5% des logements sur Airbnb sont
loués sans permis à Toronto
55,8% des propriétés sont louées sans
permis
avoir couvert ses
28,5%. Toronto et Vancouver ont passé
des régulations qui rend obligatoire
l'enregistrement des annonces de
location court terme sur le site de
Airbnb mais ils ont également fait une
entente avec un BNB justement pour que
l'annonce ne puisse pas créer s'il y a
pas de numéro d'enregistrement les
parties d'opposition soutiennent que les
logements de courte durée manquent
d'encadrement
c'est pour ça qu'on appelle un révision
de la loi et un resserrement de la loi
parce que visiblement peut pas faire
confiance avec les mains à cette
entreprise pour qu'elle agisse de façon
responsable par rapport à la crise du
logement
illégales vont continuer à perdurer
c'est si on a présentement alors que
c'est déjà pas permis dans plusieurs
villes il va continuer à en avoir même
après le 25 mars les ministres des
Finances du tourisme et de l'habitation
n'étaient pas disponible pour répondre à
nos questions ici Marie-Isabelle Rochon
Radio-Canada Montréal